it's finally here nearly 3 years after
the final chapter of the attack on Titan
manga the anime ending just aired and
man there is a lot to talk about parts
of the manga ending were cut out other
parts were straight up changed and
expanded and that set up for a potential
sequel at the end was crazy by the end
of this video you will know all the
differences in the anime ending versus
the manga ending I will explain
everything that was altered so that
you're not missing out on any important
info and I will talk about the potential
future of the attack on Titan franchise
by the way if you are anime only you
definitely missed some context from the
manga so For You especially I urge you
to watch until the very end if you enjoy
our Attack on Titan content and you want
to see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment for that YouTube
algorithm and if you want me to unleash
my final Titan form by hitting 2 million
subscribers on this channel do me a huge
favor and subscribe right now we are so
close finally this video will of course
contain a tack on Titan manga spoilers
we are talking about the ending the
Manga and Anime are finally over so
let's get into it okay the first major
difference is that in the scene where
the founder imir leaves the gate open
for the pigs to escape in the anime we
clearly see her holding a jug but in the
manga there is no jug could this be a
special magical jug okay I'm kidding
that's not a major difference but there
are some real differences the final
episode slovie adapts chapters 135
through
139 and chapter 135 of the manga is
adapted extremely Faithfully in about
the first 15 minutes of the final
episode slovie the only big question
that some anime only might have here is
about Falco and how he became the flying
Titan this was mentioned in the previous
episode but a lot of people were
confused even when this happened in the
manga so I will quickly explain it right
now because Falon was turned into a
Mindless Titan using Zeke's own spinal
fluid before he ever became the jaw
Titan shifter after becoming a Titan
shifter heed started experiencing dreams
that actually turned out to be memories
of the previous Beast Titans as the jaw
Titan he was expected to experience the
memories of former jaw Titans especially
because the previous jaw Titan was Colt
Falco's older brother so they have a
direct blood connection However the fact
that Falon was experiencing the memories
of former Beast Titans was extremely
unusual and Annie was genuinely
surprised when Falco first told her
about it on the ship Falco told Annie
that he was having vivid dreams and in
his dreams he saw that a previous Beast
Titan could actually fly through the air
not only that but Falco had the strong
feeling that he too is capable of doing
the same thing with his own Titan
transformation he believed that he could
also become a flying Titan Annie didn't
believe it at first but because Falco
was so certain they decided to try it
out when Falco successfully transformed
into a flying Titan Annie and Gabby
decided to climb on top of him and head
towards the rumbling in order to help
their friends Annie initially wanted to
sit the battle out but when a literal
flying Titan presented itself she kind
of took it as a sign that she had to
take part in that final battle chapter
136 is also adapted very Faithfully
although some scenes from chapter 134
are also included at this point these
are scenes of the rumbling destroying
countries all over the world and later
on in the final episode we see scenes of
Historia giving birth in the manga these
scenes appear earlier chronologically as
a said in chapter
134 there is one small part of chapter
136 that is omitted from the anime when
Riner first encounters Gabby Annie and
the flying Titan Falco at one point he
asks Falco if he remembers the promise
he made to Riner the promise was that
Falon would save Gabby from the dark
future they all face Falco thinks to
himself that yes of course he remembers
but for whatever reason this brief
exchange is not shown in the anime the
convo between Armen and Zeke within the
paths goes pretty much the same but
after watching it again I thought it had
some really deep philosophical meaning
that a lot of us may have rushed through
when we were first reading the manga
because we just wanted to see what
happens next Zeke has this view that all
living species including humans are
essentially just being manipulated by
nature to survive and multiply all of
their actions are driven by this need
and by the fear of death which nature
instills in them in order to motivate
them to keep living and multiply Zeke
wonders whether Dr rumbling is actually
a bad thing because all humans will die
eventually and maybe death isn't so bad
because it finally frees you from
Nature's manipulation it might actually
be a relief because at least then you no
longer have to worry about surviving and
growing and multiplying but Armen
remembers some moments in his life that
are seemingly completely trivial like
running up the hill to that tree with
his friends staying in on a rainy day to
read a book walking through the
marketplace and so on he tells Zeke that
these trivial moments have nothing to do
with with advancing the species and
multiplying and yet they are the moments
in which he was truly happy Zeke then
thinks of the time that he just randomly
played catch with Tom xaver and he
realizes that yes Armen is right even
though randomly throwing a ball back and
forth has no connection to surviving and
multiplying he would have been happy
playing catch with saer forever the
message here is that we need to live in
the present moment happiness never comes
from worrying about the past or the
future it comes from living full in the
moment enjoying the little things and
just being for being's sake in some ways
it's a very Zen perspective since Zen
teaches us that fear comes from worrying
about this and that and lamenting about
the past and future but happiness comes
from just being at one with the universe
and being one with the now when you're
sitting down don't worry about anything
don't think about anything just sit when
you're eating just eat don't be this or
that just be as Zeke is about to die he
finally realized is that maybe he should
have actually enjoyed life more
including the little things like nice
weather by the way for those of you
wondering in the scene where all the
former shifters that we know decide to
help our heroes stop Aaron and the
rumbling that Ram Titan is what Tom
xaver Beast Titan form looked like he
was the former Beast Titan before the
power was inherited by Zeke and Tom was
also Zeke's mentor and his only true
Father Figure chapter 138 the second
last chapter is also adapted quite
faithfully and this is where we get that
scene of Aaron and Mikasa in the cabin
Aaron used the paths to show Mikasa an
alternate future if Aaron had not been
able to bring himself to continue
fighting and initiate the rumbling he
and Mikasa could have enjoyed some
peaceful time together before he died
because of emir's curse but then marlay
would have invaded paradise and everyone
they know would have been killed would
this have been a happier ending I guess
I'll leave that up to you guys to decide
however it is important to note that
during this scene Aaron asks Mikasa to
promise him that after he dies she will
throw his scarf away he says that she is
going to live a long time after this
because she of course doesn't have
emir's curse so she should forget about
Aaron and be free Aaron tells her to
please forget about him and this is
something that we have to remember
because I will come back to it later it
is extremely important for understanding
Aaron's character and many have
completely misunderstood and
mischaracterized the conversation that
Aaron has with Armen about Mikasa back
in the real world Mikasa decides that
she cannot keep that promise to Aaron
she cannot throw the scarf away but she
also cannot allow this tragedy to
continue she decides that she has to be
the one to kill Aaron and she then
enters the mouth of his Colossal Titan
form and detaches Aaron's head from the
Titan in doing so she kills Aaron even
though she loves him and always will and
that brings us to probably the most
controversial scene in in the entire
series the conversation between Armen
and Aaron within the path people have
used this conversation to absolutely
assassinate Aaron's character and a lot
of stuff is either misinterpreted or
just deliberately framed in a negative
way to portray Aaron as some sort of
Crybaby incel or s or whatever if that's
what you think about Ain at the end of
this then you clearly do not understand
the ending and I'm actually considering
doing a full video on Aaron just to
explain his entire character progression
for those who are actually interested it
drop a like and let me know down in the
comments if you'd like to see that video
the convo starts off with Armen telling
Aaron that he understands why Aaron
tried to push him and Mikasa away
although Armen doesn't think that he
needed to go so far as to beat him up
and say all those hurtful things to
Mikasa Aaron wanted to push his friends
away from him in order to turn them into
the heroes who would form an
International Alliance with the Warriors
of marlay and put a stop to him and to
the rumbling the survivors of the
rumbling would then know that it was
eldians from Paradise and eldians from
arlay who came together to heroically
stop the evil Aaron and so the world
would hopefully stop demonizing all
alians on top of that since Aaron knew
that he would destroy 80% of humanity
before he was stopped even if the world
wanted to attack parades it would take
them decades if not centuries to recover
enough to launch the attack and it would
also give Paradise enough time to
prepare for any potential future attack
interestingly enough in the manga the
part about 80% of people being destroyed
in the r is revealed by Aaron early on
in the conversation he says did you
really have to go that far for our sake
but it doesn't seem nearly as freaked
out about the prospect of so many people
dying as you might expect from Armen
armen's reaction to this information was
one of the big criticisms that people
had of the Final Chapter so let's put a
pin in that for now because the anime
ending does actually change this in the
anime Aaron does not talk about the 80%
stuff yet instead he goes on to reveal
reveal the truth about the founder
emir's motivations he reveals that
despite everything that King Fritz put
emier through she actually loved him and
she spent the past 2,000 years obeying
him and doing exactly what she thought
that he would want her to do she was
striving for freedom but she was a slave
to her love this was a hugely
controversial part of the ending when it
first came out in the manga because it
makes emir's motivations just so
disappointing and tragic she is driven
by her love for her own abuser and this
leads her to kill countless people for
the sake of this man's power and
ambition I'm not saying this type of
toxic love doesn't happen in real life
but it's just so sad and so terrible
actually one of my most controversial
videos was a video where I argued that
Emir Fritz started out as a victim but
then also became a villain in her own
right there were points at which she as
an adult could have done the right thing
but she didn't so even though she is a
victim she also eventually became a
victimizer I will link that video down
in the description if you want to check
it out but yeah quite a few people felt
that she was only a victim and that my
take on this was completely wrong Aaron
says that throughout these 2,000 years
Emir has been searching through the
paths for someone to free her from her
slavery and she finally found that
person in Mikasa mikasa's headaches
throughout the series were actually
instances of the founder imir peeking
into mikasa's life through the paths
Aaron isn't sure why exactly it had to
be Mikasa but I will explain that in a
little bit Aaron then reveals something
extremely important he says that his
mind has been completely messed up by
the power of the founding Titan and
that's because the Founder's power makes
it so that there is no past or future
because the past present and future all
exist together at the same time this
leads us to another extremely
controversial moment the moment in which
Aaron reveals that he was seemingly the
one who told The Smiling Titan to leave
berol and go devour his own mother
instead because of course berol wasn't
supposed to die yet and Aaron had to
ensure that the future he knew was
inevitable would indeed come to pass
people have interpreted this as meaning
that Aaron the Aaron as an individual
character had a choice between saving
his mother and killing her and he
willingly chose to kill her but it is
not so simple and Aaron literally said
that very thing moments earlier once he
became one with the founding Titan Aaron
began to experience the past present and
future simultaneously and to him it all
felt like one and the same obviously
normal humans can't even comprehend this
concept unless you're a fully
enlightened zen master or something but
essentially because Aaron is one with
the founder he experiences the Founder's
actions even the Founder's actions from
the past as his own actions he feels
like he had a part in pushing the
smiling Titan towards his mother because
the founder did it and he he later
became one with the founder past present
and future but at the time that his
mother's death occurred Aaron was of
course his own person he was a separate
character entirely he had not yet
consumed the founding Titan power some
people seem to think that once Aaron
became one with the founder he could
literally decide to change everything he
could just change the past and save his
mother or prevent the walls from ever
being built or I don't know what else
but that is not the case the only time
Aaron affected the past directly was
when he sent future memories through the
attack Titan back to his father who was
a former attack Titan user The Smiling
Titan was not an attack Titan user so
Aaron could not have used future
memories to affect the past in that
specific situation Aaron repeatedly
states that the future he saw is
inevitable and it cannot be changed no
matter how hard he tried so it's not as
simple as Sim refusing to save his own
mother because he's just an idiot I
firmly believe that he couldn't actually
change things but because he became won
with the founder he felt like he was
partially responsible for the Founder's
past actions but it is kind of ironic
for me to say that Aron was not an idiot
because he literally calls himself an
idiot in this conversation with Armen
and that leads us to perhaps the single
most controversial aspect of the entire
ending Aaron's true feelings for Mikasa
during their convo Armen gets mad at
Aaron for telling Mikasa to just forget
about him and move on and we know that
Aaron said this to her privately in
their conversation at the imaginary
cabin because I just talked about it
earlier on in the video Aaron tried to
make her promise to throw away the scarf
and just forget about him Armen feels
that this kind of thing is cruel of him
to ask Mikasa since she has always loved
him and put him above all other things
but that's when Aaron admits to Armen
that no he doesn't really want her to
forget about him and find another man
and move on Aaron begins to cry and he
says that he wants Mikasa to think about
him and no one else for the rest of her
life and even after he died he wants her
to be hung up on him for at least 10
years Armen is surprised that Aaron
would say something so pathetic and
Aaron immediately tells Arman not to
ever repeat any of this to Mikasa
herself because he really does want her
to be happy it's just that deep within
his heart he also wants to be with
Mikasa he wants to stay with his friends
he doesn't want to die Armen tries to
convince him that they can find another
way but Aaron says that he has to
initiate the rumbling he doesn't even
know why but he has to the future is
already predetermined the future is
already happening it's already happened
it can't be changed at least that's what
Aaron believes so many people
interpreted what Aaron says about Mikasa
as an indication that he's some kind of
simp incel who wants Mikasa to suffer
because of him because that would
satisfy his own selfish ego but that's
clearly not true Aaron deliberately
pushed Mikasa away so she would no
longer love him he asked her to promise
him that she would move on and forget
about him and he even told Armen to
never never tell Mikasa what he said
about wanting her to only be with him or
only think about him for the rest of her
life this statement by Aaron was just a
human moment of weakness on his part a
moment that he shared with Armen his
friend privately Aaron is still human
he's still a teenager he's still
completely inexperienced with
relationships and some part of him
wishes that things could be different he
wishes that he didn't have to die and
that he could be with Mikasa and that
she would only love him forever but
because he knows that things can never
be that way and he will die soon he does
want her to move on even though he
wishes things could be different and
that she could only be his I really
don't know why this is so hard to
understand for some people but I do feel
like the majority of you guys get it
right okay so in the anime it is only
after the conversation about Mikasa that
Aaron reveals to Armen for the first
time that the rumbling will trample 80%
of humanity before he is inevitably
stopped by the international Alliance in
the anime Armen is visibly more upset
when he hears this than he was in the
manga and he grabs Aaron by the Coller
and angrily asks him how could you Aaron
explains that destroying 80% of the
world outside of paradise will reduce
the rest of the world to the same level
of civilization as Paradise which will
ensure that the world won't be able to
launch a one-sided reprisal that
destroys the island nevertheless Aaron
then goes on to say something else he
says that even after that this conflict
doesn't end and as he says this last
part Aaron is not talking about some
sort of philosophical hypothesis he is
stating it as fact just like he stated
all the other things as fact but how is
this possible how could Aon know about a
conflict that happens over a century or
multiple centuries after his death I
will return to this at the end of the
video because this is an important
change that the anime made to the ending
of the manga when Armen asks him to
stopped rumbling because it hasn't even
happened yet Aaron literally says that
he can't because it's already been
determined he doesn't say that he
doesn't want to stop it he says he can't
he even adds that he tried to change the
future many times but no matter what he
does no matter how many times he tests
the different scenarios things always
occur exactly the same way they did in
his memories of the future if you go
back to this conversation in chapter 139
of the manga the anime actually adds a
lot so this is probably the key change
that the anime ending makes in the manga
it is not so clear that Aaron can't
change the future but the anime ending
makes this a lot clearer Aaron wanted to
save paradise and his friends but he
didn't necessarily want to kill 80% of
humanity to do it not unless he
absolutely had to he tried to avoid it
but no matter what he did it was always
inevitable because it was always
predetermined in the anime Aaron even
tells Armen that he is a slave to
Freedom he wanted Freedom so badly but
in order to attain it he became a slave
to the founder and the timeline that the
founder was inevitably following he
wanted to protect his friends but he
failed and he asks himself why did it
turn out this way he clearly regrets
that things had to be this way and even
calls himself an idiot which by the way
is not in the manga Aaron says that if
he wasn't an idiot maybe another
resolution could have been possible but
he could not find it and so this became
the only possible outcome now at one
point Point Aaron does say that some
part of him wanted to see the world
outside of paradise as blank planes free
of humans just like he and Armen had
dreamed about back when they thought
that Humanity had gone extinct beyond
the walls this was his fantasy of true
freedom of Breaking Free from the walls
and then being able to go wherever he
wanted and do whatever he wanted without
worrying about other humans and their
Wars and conflicts and other problems
Armen says that he shares in this sin
because he contributed to Aaron
developing this false idea about the
outside world by showing him books and
telling him stories about a vast and
completely uninhabited World beyond the
walls Armen then says that the two of
them will see each other again in hell
if it exists where they will both have
to pay for the sin of killing off 80% of
humanity I will say that the anime does
a much better job of showcasing anime's
true character in this conversation in
the manga he was quick to accept the
fact that Aaron kills 80% of humanity
but in the anime he is far more set and
he later says that they both belong in
hell for the sin of allowing this to
happen so kudos to the anime for that I
have to admit that the part about Aaron
saying that he kind of wanted to flatten
the world did confuse me a bit because
it contradicts his earlier statement
about trying to change the outcome and
regretting that he couldn't change it
but I'm just going to assume that this
is Aaron saying that a part of him
wishes that armen's innocent fantasy of
an uninhabited World outside was true
because if it were that would mean true
freedom without problems and conflicts a
fictional vast and endless Wilderness is
what would have made Armen and Aaron
truly free but it was not to be because
that is not what the outside world was
overall I think that the anime ending
makes this conversation a lot better
although it's still not perfect and I
feel like isama really struggled to get
what he wanted to say across in this
dialogue I don't know if he needed more
scenes or something else but it just
isn't as clear as it could be although
again it's better than the manga after
Aaron is killed by Mikasa Emir can
finally move on and the power of the
Titans disappears from the world this is
because Mikasa showed imir that even if
you truly love someone you can let them
go so just as Mikasa chose to end
Aaron's life to save the world even
though she truly loved him Emir chose to
finally stop obeying the will of King
Fritz even though she truly loved him
Mikasa then takes Aaron's head and
leaves the battlefield because she
believed that the others wouldn't let
her get give Aaron a proper burial you
know they might want to like destroy the
head just in case but mikas is like no
let's bury the head beneath the tree at
top the hill where Aaron used to take a
nap as a kid what could possibly go
wrong 3 years later the island of
paradise has created a modern Army to
help them fight any potential foreign
Invasion that might come from the
remaining 20% of the world at the same
time the international Heroes who stop
the rumbling are working as ambassadors
for peace and trying to negotiate
between paradise and the rest of the
world through diplomacy they're trying
to decrease the possibility of future
conflict and then we get to a clear
difference between the anime and the
manga right at the very end as time
passes and Aaron's tree grows the town
below continues to expand until it
reaches all around the tree in the Manga
version of the ending we see Modern
Skyscrapers around the tree and these
are the kind of skyscrapers that you
would see in our own world that is when
another major conflict occurs airplanes
bomb the buildings anti-aircraft missile
batteries shoot back at the airplanes
and eventually the city is destroyed and
what's left is a post-apocalyptic
landscape in the manga we are led to
believe that this new conflict happens
about a 100 years after the rumbling
kind of like the equivalent of the
distance between say World War I and our
own modern world right now but in the
anime it is very different the buildings
that we see sprouting around the tree do
become regular modern buildings at one
point but then they continue to grow and
evolve until they become futuristic
cyberpunk buildings like something you
might see in Blade Runner or Ghost in
the Shell that is when the new conflict
occurs meaning that in the anime ending
the years of Peace last much longer
we're talking maybe even several
centuries instead of just about a 100
years eventually though the conflict
does occur and we still get the
post-apocalyptic landscape just like in
the manga we see that same child with a
dog wandering the post-apocalyptic
wilderness and the child eventually
stumbles upon Aaron's tree not only is
the tree still there but it is now
absolutely massive and it looks eily
similar to the tree that the founder yir
stumbled upon before she was turned into
a Titan BY that glowing centipede
creature in the manga ending the child
is seen at the foot of the tree and
there is a large cavernous opening there
just like with emir's tree but in the
manga the child is still some ways away
from the tree so you're left to wonder
whether the child will go into the
cavern or not in the anime it is very
clear that the child is about to walk
into the cavern and so the cycle is
about to repeat itself just like Zeke
said life continues to multiply and the
centipede creature found a way to
reproduce itself mikasa's decision to
bury Aaron's head under that tree
spawned another centipede creature which
took over another tree and although the
power of the Titans had disappeared from
the world after Emir decided to stop
obeying the will of King Fritz that
power will now return to the world as
the child from the very end enters that
opening beneath the tree personally I
absolutely loved this final part of the
ending because it does such a great job
of reinforcing the most important theme
in Attack on Titan human nature leads
humans to try to survive and multiply
and yet unfortunately it also leads them
to wage war against each other so much
of human history is an endless cycle of
war and suffering and with or without
the power of titans this doesn't change
I mean just look at our own world and
you'll see that this is true all our
modern technology and access to all the
information in the world still can't
stop us from Waging War on each other
the rumbling led to centuries of Peace
for Paradise but eventually it was
destroyed by War and let's face it even
if Aaron's rumbling destroyed 100% of
humanity outside the island it's likely
that the humans on the island would have
then just started fighting each other
Attack on Titan was never an idealistic
story about how Humanity can move Beyond
war and suffering it was always a
brutally realistic portrayal of how
Humanity has actually been acting
throughout history not what we wish we
could be or what we sometimes pretend to
be at the same time the child at the end
proves that despite all the war and
suffering Humanity remains resilient if
that child and that dog survived the
apocalyptic conflict that we saw at the
end then others surely survived as well
so Humanity continues to live in spite
of it all and this is where I want to
remind you of the statement that Aaron
made in his conversation with Armen at
least in the anime version of the ending
he said that even after the rumbling
this conflict doesn't end and he said it
as a fact not as some personal Theory or
speculation now as far as we know major
conflict on Paradise did end after
Aaron's death at least for a few hundred
years so could it be that Aaron saw the
future memories of that kid at the end
the new founding Titan and that's how he
knew that even long after the rumbling
and his own death the conflict doesn't
end could it be that some part of Aaron
is still alive in that new centipede
creature and Will some part of Aaron
live on within the new founding Titan
those are some intriguing questions for
a potential Attack on Titan sequel I'm
not saying that there will be a sequel
especially since isama had such a hard
time with the ending and with everyone's
reaction to the ending but if he did
ever want to make a futuristic
postapocalyptic Attack on Titan sequel
he definitely did a good job of setting
it up there at the very end what do you
guys think of the new anime ending and
do you agree with my points in this
video I personally think that the anime
ending is significantly better than the
manga ending although it's still not
perfect it doesn't change the
fundamentals of the ending but it does
fix some issues and it adds a additional
context that is much appreciated that
said although I do have my critiques of
the ending I think that the overall
story of Attack on Titan is phenomenal
easily a 9.5 out of 10 if you'd like me
to make that full video on Aaron that I
mentioned earlier let me know down in
the comments and subscribe if I see a
lot of new subscribers coming in from
this video I will take it as a sign that
you want to see the Aaron video If
you're looking for more attack atin
content right now check out that video I
made about imir Fritz being a villain
link on screen scre and in the
description right now